es war wirklich einer der
spektakulärsten funde der letzten jahre
die mumie eines wesens das tatsächlich
ziemlich so aussah wie wir uns in
unserer phantasie ein alien vorstellen
der riesige kopf der lange schmale
körper sollten die mediendarstellung
also doch der realität entsprechen
vor 15 jahren wurde die mumie in einer
verlassenen stadt in der atacama wüste
in chile gefunden was ist also mit der
endung mobi auf sich hat jetzt den
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen das war schon der aktion
spektakulärer fund vor 15 jahren in der
kleinen verlassenen stadt la noria in
der atacama wüste in chile die
trockenste wüste der welt die mumie war
extrem klein hatte aber die proportionen
eines erwachsenen es war eine absolute
sensation doch zu einer
wissenschaftlichen untersuchung kam es
nie schon kurz nach der entdeckung wurde
die mumie verkauft und entzog sich damit
einer genaueren extrahierung doch
irgendwann landete die mumie auf einem
info logan congress in barcelona und kam
damit zumindest ihnen die nähe von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ein team um gary nordin
untersucht die die mobilen dann 2013 zum
ersten mal vor fünf jahren begann er
dann die dna sequenzierung und das
ergebnis war dann einerseits erwartet
aber auch ein bisschen seltsam das
erbgut war zu 91% menschlich der rest
war durch die verwesung zerstört worden
und überrascht war das forschungsteam
vom zustand der knochen demnach lebte
dieses kind nämlich und wurde sogar
sechs oder sieben jahre alt war sehr
seltsam jetzt hat das forschungsteam
seinen abschlussbericht vorgelegt und
muss ich korrigieren
demnach war die mumie wohl doch ein
frühchen das aufgrund zahlreicher
genetische veränderung nicht lebensfähig
war es war kleinwüchsig hatte eine
skoliose also eine verkrümmung der
wirbelsäule und noch andere
fehlbildungen der muskeln und knochen
und schwere stoffwechselerkrankungen
haben wohl zu der falschen analyse der
knochen geführt jetzt ist klar das kind
starb vor der geburt als fotos dass
diese erkenntnisse jetzt alle so gut
erzielt werden von lag vor allem am
fundort in der trockenste wüste der welt
wurde die leiche besonders gut
konserviert werden als erstes neues zu
solchen themen erfahren wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion vom klicks und mitmachen und
mit themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen
was ja bei pixum passiert der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
aliens können wir sie leichter finden
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran